in the red corner we ended thirty-six
solar masses the reigning champion Big
Brother black Hall blow in the blue
corner weighing in at 29 solar masses
the Challenger little brother Black Hawk
alone it's going to be a fight how will
it end
let's find out was his physics hey crazy
some of you were wondering if I was ever
going to do a video on gravitational
waves well now's the time I realized the
hype is over and there are already a ton
of videos about this but there's still
some connections that need to be made
and some very misleading visuals that
need to be addressed plus it doesn't
hurt to get your information from
multiple sources especially with
something that's weird and crazy so
let's get back to those black hole
clones as the black hole clone circle
each other they move closer and closer
and speed up in the process eventually
there's a connection does one go down
for the count no don't be ridiculous
this is astrophysics the two combine
into one giant black hole clone they're
like a cosmic Voltron Voltron defender
of the universe very successful cartoon
someone has to know Voltron I am so old
anyway the new giant black hole is 62
solar masses which might leave you
thinking isn't 36 plus 29 65 not 62 and
why weren't their orbits stable both
very good questions and both have the
same answer gravitational waves sea
waves are a big deal because they move
energy from one place to another without
having to move matter from one place to
another that's the definition of a way
they're so useful than not one but two
of our senses have evolved the detect
them
mechanical waves are waves in matter
like strings air the earth or water
those are the kind you think of when I
say the word wave light is also a wave
but in electric and magnetic fields
instead of matter we did a whole video
on light if you're interested since
there isn't a lot of matter in space
light was the only way we were able to
find astronomical stuff stars like the
Sun emit visible light so we can see
them but planets like Jupiter don't so
we have to wait for light from the Sun
to get their bounce off and then come to
earth before we can see it unfortunately
not everything can emit or reflect
enough light black holes and neutron
stars for example sometimes we get
he and those things pull in matter that
we can see but otherwise we're left in
the dark
that's why gravitational waves are such
a big deal they're a whole new type of
wave Wiggles in the fabric of space-time
itself but that means they behave a
little differently than other types of
waves so let's be careful for something
one-dimensional like this ribbon
you only need one number to represent
its curvature for curvature on a
two-dimensional surface you also only
need one number but the same cannot be
said for higher dimensions so this is a
terrible graphic for space-time for
curvature within a three-dimensional
space you need six numbers for curvature
within a four-dimensional space-time
like our universe you need 20 numbers
which results in ten independent
Einstein equations those equations
describe all the curvature that results
in gravitational motion but not all
curvature creates waves you can't have
anything that's spherically or
cylindrically symmetric so a lonely
spinning black hole probably isn't going
to do it but two black holes orbiting
each other will just like our black hole
clones from earlier and that's exactly
what LIGO detected on September 14th
2015
what's LIGO the coolest thing to happen
in experimental physics since the LHC
LIGO stands for laser interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory they
detect gravitational waves using lasers
about 1.3 billion years ago a 36 solar
mass black hole in a 20-9 solar mass
black hole collided to form a 62 solar
mass black hole releasing gravitational
waves carrying three solar masses worth
of energy and then those waves traveled
1.3 billion light years to reach Earth
how do we even know all of that okay I
guess that's a fair question the easiest
things to measure about a wave are
frequency and energy but that's plenty
of you can do some physics the frequency
of the wave is twice the orbital speed
of the black holes using general
relativity orbital speed gives us the
masses of the black holes and those
masses tell us the energy they're going
to lose during the merger that energy
spreads thinner the farther a travels
until it finally arrives at LIGO
comparing the predicted energy to the
energy Lego actually received gives us
the distance to the black hole's
Direction is a little harder we don't
aim LIGO like a telescope it just sits
there
on the surface of the earth and monitors
all directions at once which is partly
why we made two different observatories
one is in Louisiana and the other is in
Washington State
Louisiana detected the event a whole
seven milliseconds before Washington and
since we know gravitational waves travel
at the speed of light we can get a
direction well roughly anyway
LIGO could only narrow down the location
of the merger to an area of the sky
measuring 600 square degrees which is a
little under 1% of the sky but that's
pretty impressive considering it
monitors out to five billion light-years
using two and a half mile long vacuum
tubes containing lasers that change in
length by a fraction of the width of a
proton and since LIGO showed proof of
concept other countries are now building
their own which is going to make our
measurements much more precise it's a
great time to be alive thanks for liking
and sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to see more
science like this and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
[Music]